do you want to learn how to grow maize
more sustainably
to get started select the best maize
variety
and create a crop calendar for next
season with extension officers in your
area
buy certified seeds accessible at the
agro-dealer
recommended by the agri-business hubs
the right varieties match local climate
and are adapted to low soil fertility
[Music]
for commercial production use hybrid
varieties that have
high yield and are disease tolerant you
can still use
open pollinated local variety these are
often
tastier and easier to store due to their
hard grains
in high rainfall areas agricultural
region 3
use late maturity varieties planted at
the beginning of the rainy season
between 1st and 30th november use medium
maturity varieties
between 1st and 25th december use
early maturity varieties from 25th
december
to 5th january in medium rainfall areas
agroecological region 2a and
agroecological region 2b
if you only have late maturity varieties
plant them very early before 20th
november
use medium maturity varieties between
20th november
to 15 december use early maturity
varieties between 15th to the 25th of
december
in low rainfall areas agroecological
region 1
use early maturity varieties at the
beginning of the rainy season
between 15 november to the 15th december
planting before rainy season is risky
too little rainfall
poor soil moisture will lead to poor
germination
and loss of sea
every three to four years test soil
acidity and magnesium through the help
of extension
officers three to six months before
planting this test is especially
important in high rainfall
areas where soils are naturally acidic
to make sure your soil restores a ph
of 5.5 to 7 apply lime
three weeks before planting
a field with plenty of crop residues
will help the soil to stay in place
retain water and become more fertile in
order to achieve the benefits of crop
residue retention
discuss with your community and make
resolutions to improve
crop residue management and control
grazing
further to crop residue retention use of
cover crops
agroforestry and livestock manure
can all contribute towards improved soil
fertility
and the sustainable production of maize
recommendations from extension officers
project staff and or the agri-business
hubs on suppliers
can help you access the right equipment
to manage your needs
based on your farm size and available
resources
field extension officers recommend the
best mechanization systems for you
for best yields consider planting depth
density and spacing in good rainfall
areas with
fertile soils and proper nutrient
management
aim for four to five plants per square
meter
forty four thousand two fifty five
thousand plants per hectare
in areas with low rainfall and or
limited application of nutrients
aim for three to four plants per square
meter
thirty three thousand to forty thousand
plants per hectare choosing the distance
between plants
depends on the equipment and the amount
of labor available
here is a maize spacing guide
[Music]
here is a fertilizer and manure compost
application rate guide
if you are using a jab planter plant one
seed per station for
optimum yield limited labor plant up to
three seeds in the same station
if you are using furrow planting plant
each seed
at equal distance check the field
regularly until
week six if there are weeds lightly
scratch the surface with a hand hole
hand weeder or a cultivator
if you want to use herbicides you must
be trained on how to select
nozzles and calibrate sprayers by
qualified staff
you can receive more information from
extension officers
and the hub if you are using chemical
fertilizer four weeks after planting
apply urea 20 centimeters away from the
plant
covering the urea with soil will help
reduce nitrogen loss from volatilization
in dry weather
and runoff during heavy rain where
possible
the top dressing should be combined with
weeding either using a hole or
cultivator
if you are using minimum tillage
practices use spot application and
cover the area with a hole or make a 10
centimeter deep hole with a stick
place the urea in the hole and cover
loam soil
apply all the urea at week four
sandy soil apply half of the urea at
week 4
and apply the rest at week 7.
harvest can be done by hand or you can
ask the hub
where services are available
find out more about fao's approach to
climate smart crop production
you